le restaurant le mousseau au
centre-ville de montréal a fait un grand
virage au cours des derniers mois
qualité de vie le propriétaire entonnait
mousson rivard ne l'ouvrent maintenant
que trois soirs par semaine et les
postes de serveurs ont été abolies pour
donner entre autres meilleurs salaires
aux cuisiniers se laisser la jalade
aremo mis à terre de trois fois
le propriétaire du restaurant au pied de
cochon lui martin picard a essuyé un
flot de critiques pour avoir affiché un
poste de cuisinier avec un salaire de 13
$ 50 l'heure il s'est défendu prétextant
qu avec les pourboires ses employés aux
fourneaux gagne plutôt autour de 18 $
l'heure est fréquent en fait que les
salaires sont très bas dans les
restaurants
et puis haut de gamme est souvent tout
les arts confessons aux pays non cette
cuisinière a quitté montréal après avoir
travaillé dans plusieurs restaurants
dont le toqué la plupart dit elles
n'offrent pas de bonnes conditions de
travail
font pas de faire l'arrêt norme unique
ironisant et des châteaux il mène pas en
rolls royce sont les premiers à mettre
des heures de travail
justement le modèle doit changer le
professeur en gestion de l'it et hq
l'institut de tourisme et d'hôtellerie
du québec explique qu'en moyenne pour
100 dollars de revenus un restaurateur
paie environ 34 $ pour la nourriture 33
$ pour la main d'oeuvre 18 $ pour le
loyer et 10 pour d'autres frais si bien
que la marge de profit ne dépasse que
très rarement 5% l'une des solutions
serait d'augmenter le prix des plats ce
que plusieurs refusent de faire si le
client en martin elliott business donc
fausse d'abord s'assurer d'avoir de
l'achalandage et pour assurer cet
achalandage
on veut maintenir des prix le plus beau
possible mais au mousseau un repas pour
2 peut coûter jusqu'à 900 dollars nous
servirons on offre plus que 13 et 50
même que salaire de base de plongeurs et
est plus élevé que la moyenne des
salaires de cuisiniers de base un
changement de culture pourrait bien être
en train de s'opérer ici sébastien
desrosiers radio canada morrell